[Musique]
et notre invité c'est Antoine Basbous
bonjour merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation vous êtes politologue
fondateur et directeur de l'Observatoire
des pays arabes et auteur de ce livre le
tsunami arabe s'est paru chez Fayard on
est ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview avec la presse régionale
représentée par Christelle Bertron du
groupe la pêche bonjour Christelle
bonjour Rian bonjour Antoine Basbous
bonjour madame monsieur Basbous
benjamine netaniaou a répété hier pas de
cesser le feu sans libération des otages
est-ce qu'on va vers un conflit qui dure
en tout cas on est on est rentré dans le
deuxèe mois de ce
conflit rien n'a été résolu les morts se
comptent par milliers on n'est plus au
18e siècle où il faudra attendre des
mois pour avoir des photos nous les
avons nous avons les images en direct et
on peut pas être insensible à ce que
nous voyons comme déluge de feu comme
massacre de côté et d'autre et d'où ces
appels de la communauté internationale
qui se multiplie appelle à une trêve
humanitaire est-ce que Beniamin et
taniaou il est sensible à ces appels où
est-ce qu'ils sont sans effet sur lui à
vrai dire Israël a pris un très gros
coup le 7 octobre et donc il était la
puissance dissuasive de la région elle
est Israël est tombé très bas avec ce
coul et maintenant tout ce que fait
Israël c'est de redresser de retrouver
cette stature de dissuasion régionale et
pour cela il il Israël frappe très fort
fait une gu une guerre totale il réduit
Gaza à à la en état de cendre et en même
temps c'est la terre brûlée qu'il exerce
au prix de de de pertes civiles
extrêmement importantes qui sont
constatées et regretté et condamnées par
le secrétaire général de l'ONU et par
beaucoup d'agences de de de
international ce que vous voulez dire
c'est que les appels à la paix qui
émanent partout du monde entier ne sont
pas entendus ils ne sont pas audibles
aujourd'hui non il ils ne sont pas
entendus il y a plusieurs agendas à
Israël d'abord retrouver sa stature de
puissance régionale incontestée
incontestable aussi il y a un agenda
intérieur en Israël c'est-à-dire
netanahou qui qui a régné sur le pays
depuis 2 1900 presque s discontin
continué avec un épisode à la fin des
années 90 et bien aujourd'hui il doit
rendre des comptes sur ce qui est arrivé
et sur le désastre du 7 octobre donc il
veut prolonger dépasser et peut-être il
y a des des
objectif stratégique voire messianique
de pousser les Palestiniens de Gaza vers
l'Égypte vers le Sinaï pour s'en
débarrasser en quelque sorte et nettoyer
cette bande de sorte qu'il n'y ait plus
de palest à Gaza est-ce que vous diriez
aujourd'hui que Benjamin naniaou est
fragilisé en Israël ou pas du tout
évidemment il suffit de regarder les
sondages il est il est tombé très bas et
d'un côté et de l'autre lui-même
reconnaît qu'il va y avoir une
commission d'enquête et qu'il va avoir
des comptes à rendre évidemment israël
est une démocratie
euh pour les Juifs entre les Juifs et
cette démocratie à chaque fois a euh
constitué des commissions d'enquête et
des commissions d'enquête qui ne
plaisantaiit pas les les dirigeants ont
dû payer
euh les les erreurs qu'ils ont commis
qu'est-ce quelle conséquence cela
pourrait avoir en Israël cette
fragilisation de Benjamin netaniao sa
crédibilité est entamée et parler
aujourd'hui de l'avenir de Gaza après la
destruction de Gaza par quelqu'un qui
n'est pas censé rester là donc c'est une
question qui se pose oui qu quand quand
il dit juste en parlant de l'avenir de
Gaza il dit Israël assumera pour une
durée indéterminée la responsabilité
générale de la sécurité dans la bande de
Gaza comment il faut comprendre cette
déclaration c'est je pense de la
rhétorique et de la politique intérieure
d'ailleurs il a été aussitôt contredit
par le Parin américain qui ne tolère pas
ceci qui ne veut pas cautionner ce
retour cette de l'occupation israélienne
à Gaza parce que en faisant cela netania
détruit 45 années de Pacific tion de
normalisation avec une dizaine de pays
arabes il y avait une dynamique que
l'Iran et le Hamas ont cassé et
aujourd'hui ces pays-là ne peuvent pas
s'afficher au côté d'Israël ne peuvent
pas s'afficher au côté des États-Unis et
d'ailleurs les États-Unis est en train
de perdre son influence y compris dans
ses pays alliés donc on va en parler
mais pour vous pour Benjamin netanahou
ça voulait dire réoccuper Gaza c'est ce
qu'il a dit et il a été contredit autant
par la Maison Blanche que par certains
de ses ministres il cons il n'y a pas
consensus en Israël et les américains
restent tout de même extrêmement frileux
à vrai dire les Américains permettent
autorisent tous les caprices d'Israël
depuis 75 ans les Américains parlent
disent qu'il faut avoir deux États mais
jamais ils n'exerce de pression ou ne
menace de sanction et quand Barak Obama
l'avait
fait lors de son premier mandat en
disant si vous continuez la colonisation
de l'assis Jordanie j'arrête le
financement et bien netaniao l'a défié
au Congrès dans un discours de 47
minutes où il a été applaudi debout par
les congressman 48 fois donc euh Israël
c'est Israël qui dirige en quelque sorte
la politique américain comment vous
expliquez cette faiblesse des Américains
face à Israël ils n'ont pas la volonté
de tordre le bras à Israël RA Israël a
une vision que le temps joue pour lui et
que il va pouvoir
installer la la comment dirais-je
purification en quelque sorte entre le
Jourdan et la Méditerranée qu'il y ait
une domination israélienne d'ailleurs
Israël n'a jamais montré qu'elles
étaient les frontières définitive de
l'État et je me rappelle avoir lu un
livre de Shimon Perez quand ancien
Premier ministre il était à l'époque
secrétaire particulier et traducteur de
Ben Gouron quand il a été reçu à
l'Élysée par de Gaul et de Gaul l'amène
après le rendez-vous dans le jardin de
l'Élysée lui dit dites-moi Bouron
quelles sont les frontières définitives
de l'État d'Israël et Benon réfléchit et
lui dit ça sera fonction du nombre de
Juifs qui feront leur allias leur allias
c'est leur monté en Israël de ce fait ce
flou reste là et les États-Unis ne ne
disent pas à Israël bon maintenant on va
établir des frontières on va les
défendre on va vous soutenir mais à côté
de vous la paix P exige qu'il y ait des
Palestiniens avec un état et des
frontières Isral est-ce que c'est pas le
fait d'avoir mis la poussière sous le
tapis pendant des années qui leur
revient en boomerang aux États-Unis
depuis le 7 octobre et est-ce que du
coup ils vont devoir changer leur
logiciel et se réinvestir dans la
recherche d'une solution politique en
tout cas c'est pas netanahou qui va
devoir faire ça ce n'est pas son
ministre de l'intérieur ni son ministre
des Finances qui sont des messianiques
supréacistes qui veulent la colonisation
qui veulent pousser les 6 jordaniens
palestiniens en Jordanie et les les
Palestiniens de Gaza en Égypte donc
c'est pas ce ce cette équipe là qui va
changer de logiciel en revanche quand on
regarde le passé Israël avait chassé
l'OLP de beyouth Arafat rappelez-vous en
82 a dû quitter beyouth avec ses forces
et bien ils ont rebondi ailleurs il y a
eu après Oslo il y a eu après le retour
d'Arafat à à Gaza puis en 6 Jordanie
bref l'histoire n'est pas figée et il
n'y a pas d'acquis de ce côté-là il va
falloir chercher la paix je pense que
l'israéliens seront plus heureux de ne
pas entendre les sirènes tous les jours
et aller descendre aux abris euh qu'avec
des des voisins avec lesquels ils sont
en paix et tout le monde se retrouve
comme
desqu quelle équipe alors pour chercher
la paix et est-ce que c'est pas une vue
de l'esprit cette solution à deux états
il y a 500000 colons en 6 Jordanie
est-ce qu'il y en a d'autres solutions
il y en a pas d'autres à mon avis parce
que les Palestiniens ne vont pas
abandonn ils ont subi énormément de de
de claques de défaites de combats perdus
mais on les voit aujourd'hui toujours en
train de rebondir donc s'il faut trouver
une paix la paix passe par
l'établissement de deux États à court
terme Dominique de Villepin assuré hier
qu'il fallait mettre en place une
administration temporaire internationale
sous les git de l'ONU euh sur la bande
de casa afin de démilitariser Gaza euh
est-ce que ça peut être une solution
envisageable pourquoi pas mais l'ONU a
toujours été molle on voit de l'autre
côté de la frontière la résolution 1701
et la finule qui est qui est entre les
deux pays la finule n'a jamais empêché
la militarisation du Sud Liban par le
Hezbollah qui détient près de 200000
missiles et qui tous les jours a commis
un coup d'État au Liban il a pris le
Liban en otage et c'est lui qui
s'installe à la frontière à la place de
l'armée libanaise donc la finine c'est
la force internationale de des
nationsies au libantion donc les
solutions husiennes restent molles
restent faibles mais il va falloir
trouver une solution qui passe par les
États-Unis ou les Nations Unies de sorte
à mais est-ce que là depuis le début du
conflit l'ONU fait pas la démonstration
de sa faiblesse l'ONU a eu le courage de
parler le secrétaire général des Nations
Unies guérrez a dit et redit des choses
extrêmement fortes qui ont déplu à
Israël les agences de l'ONU ont
également exprimer leur désapprobation
évidemment quand la communauté
internationale est divisée l'ONU reflète
ses division et et et in la faiblesse
sauf que sur le plan moral l'ONU n'a pas
failli alors qu'elle n'a pas la capacité
de d'être conséquente conséquente avec
elle-même sur un dernier mot sur les les
États-Unis parce que Anthony blincen
était en tourné dans la région ces
quelques jours le secrétaire d'État
américain notamment pour faire pression
sur Israël pour protéger les civils
palestiniens est-ce qu'il a les moyens
de faire pression là-dessus s'il y a la
volonté il y a les moyens sauf que les
Américains ne sont pas très crédibles
par rapport à Israël il lui passent tous
les caprice euh ils sont plus crédibles
par rapport aux Arabes parce que ils ont
beaucoup reculer rappelez-vous la
Somalie rappelez-vous Beyrouth en 83 ils
se sont retirés la France aussi après
avoir subi de lourdes pertes
rappelez-vous plus récemment l'échec de
la guerre en Irak l'échec de de de de du
conflit en Afghanistan et surtout le
retrait humiliant de l'armée américaine
d'Afghanistan ça fait 2 ans que ça s'est
passé donc tout ça fait que les
Américains n'ont plus la crédibilité ni
auprès d'Israël qui les mènent par le au
bout du nez ni auprès des arabes qui ont
bien compris qu'ils ne seront jamais la
puissance les Américains sont sur le
retrait dans cette région du monde ils
n'ont pas envie de se défendre
d'ailleurs à une certaine époque les
États-Unis s'approvisionner en pétrole
de la région aujourd'hui les États-Unis
sont le premier exportateur de pétrole
grâce au au pétrole et gaz de schiste
donc de ce fait ils se sont ils se
sentent beaucoup beaucoup plus
indépendant par rapport à la région leur
centre d'intérêt était la Chine l'Asie
puis avec la guerre en Ukraine de
contenir la poussée russe maintenant ce
conflit qui arrive réveille un peu les
Américains mais ils n'ont pas la
crédibilité pour être respecté en Israël
et craind dans les pays arabes justement
face à ce recul américain quel est le
rôle de la Russie aujourd'hui dans ce
conflit on en parle peu est-ce qu'il y a
est-ce qu'il y a un rôle de Vladimir
Poutine dans ce conflit on présume qu'il
n'est pas loin de la décision
euh de l'Iran qui a planté des proxis
autour d'Israël et
qui manage un peu euh les ses proxis qui
qui est le chef d'orchestre d'autant
plus que l'Iran c'est l'Iran qui fournit
les drones et les missiles à la Russie
ils sont extrêmement proches en ce
moment ils sont alliés ils sont déployés
côte à côte en Syrie ils s'entendent
bien donc ça ça soulage ça soulage
Vladimir Poutine en Ukraine ça déplace
le le le front du conflit international
au levent et pour lui c'est tout
bénéfice en quelque sorte justement sur
le le rôle des pays dans la région
Hassad nasrala le chef du hzbollah a
pris la parole vendredi dernier pour la
première fois depuis le début du conflit
ce discours il était présenté comme un
possible tournant dans le conflit or il
a écartter l'option d'une guerre totale
contre Israël pas d'ultimatum non plus
comment il faut comprendre ce discours
du chef du hasb le chef de hzbollah est
un soldat dans l'armée de wali FAQ c'est
lui qui le dit et qui le répète wali FAQ
c'est l'ayat Kham en Iran et dans le
bureau de de nasallah il y a le deux
portrait au-dessus de sa tête de son
bureau celle de Khomeini et le portrait
de khamenï donc deux portraits donc
c'est un pion dans la stratégie
iranienne c'est un préfet chef
suprmeésid président iranien c'est le
c'est un préfet en quelque sorte iranien
dans la colonie libanaise donc il agit
selon les instructions de téran alors il
a des acquis énormes au Liban le
hzbollah il a conquis ce pays c'est une
colonie iranienne il gère tout la
politique l'administration les finances
l'armée voilà il a un pays et surtout il
a une république narco maintenant qui
exporte le captagon la drogue du de
synthèse qui rapporte énormément
d'argent donc il n'a pas envie de perdre
ce statut et de perdre cette colonie en
s'affrontant directement à Israël mais
le jour où les instructions de Teran
arrivent il faut y aller il ne pourra
pas reculer
euh ça veut dire il ne pourra pas
reculer ça veut dire que si téran dit on
fait la guerre contre Israël le hzbollah
IR en évidemment et maintenant il y a il
y a un glissement il y a un glissement
progressif dans cette escalade vers la
guerre si
Israël est assuré d'un succès à Gaza à
ce moment-là il peut se retourner vers
le Hezbollah contre le Hezbollah et et
et détruire ses forces sans s'engager
dans une guerre terrestre au Liban qui
ne lui a jamais réussi mais comment le
discours de de nasrala il a été perçu
dans le monde arabe il y avait une
certaine inquiétude en attendant ce
discours est-ce que ça a été un
soulagement euh il y avait beaucoup
d'attentes les Palestiniens euh
s'attendait à ce que Nasrallah déclare
la guerre parce que l'unité des fronts
qui a été défendu par Nasrallah contre
l'ennemi sioniste qu' a qualifié décrit
comme étant fragile comme une toile
d'araignée euh et et puis du coup il n'a
rien décrété il a félicité les Yéménites
qui sont à 1700 km d'Israël d'avoir
lancé quelques drones qui sont jamais
arrivés alors que lui il suffit de faire
deux pas pour traverser la frontière et
envoyer ses troupes en Israël donc il y
avait beaucoup d'hypocrisie qui euh qui
qui a été décrite ainsi par des
dirigeants palestiniens et beaucoup de
déception dans l'axe de la résistance
auquel euh il appartient et dont il est
l'un des idéologues en quelque sorte
vous diriez qu'on a évité un embrasement
général de la région à court terme au
moins non on n'est pas dans
l'embrasement général mais on n'est pas
non plus dans la paix il y a la guerre à
Gaza il y a les affrontements en
6jordanie on est à peu près à 140 morts
depuis le 7 octobre de de de 6
jordaniens Palestiniens qui sont tués
soit par des colons protégés par l'armée
soit par l'armée directement israélienne
il y a le front du Liban au Liban le
hzbouah a perdu jusque-l plus de 60
miliciens euh plus les civils qui sont
morts du côté d'Israël il y a quelques
quelques personnes soldats ou civils qui
sont également morts la guerre on glisse
en quelque sorte vers un embrasement de
plus en plus fort ça veut dire que de ce
discours de nasral il faut pas
comprendre que l'Iran n'a pas envie d'un
conflit généralisé
l'Iran c'est un pays une civilisation
une société extrêmement patiente
dites-vous que pour fabriquer un petit
tapis et bien toute la famille s'y met
ils mettent plus d'un an pour fabriquer
donc c'est et en plus il joue avec les
proxis c'est pas du sang Perse qui est
versé c'est du sang arabe donc ils s'en
foutent un peu ce sont des joueurs
d'échec donc ils vont
calibrer ce qui a été révélateur c'est
la proposition du ministre iranien des
Affaires étrangères à l'ONU en disant le
Hamas propose de nous remettre à nous
iraniens les otages donc l'Iran cherche
une place sur leschiquier de la
négociation régional l'Iran ne veut pas
affronter ni provoquer directement les
États-Unis au point de dire à leur proxy
iraakiens tirez sur les bases
américaines mais ne les touchez pas et
du coup là tous les jours il y a des
missiles et des drones qui tombent au
côté de des bases américaines hier il y
en a un qui n'était pas armé donc il est
tombé il n'a pas explosé bref ils ne
veulent pas aller directement au conflit
donc ils veulent occuper montrer leur
capacités et dire venez négocier avec
nous nous sommes les maîtres de la
région les Arabes vos amis les arabes on
les a écartés puisqu'ils sont honteux
d'avoir signé la paix avec Israël et
avoir normalisé donc la nouvelle
puissance régionale c'est
théran un mot sur la Turquie quand même
puisqueon on a entendu Erdogan dire
qu'il soupçonnait les puissances
occidentales de créer je le cite une
atmosphère de croisade à l'encontre du
Croissant dont compte les musulmans quel
rôle joue-t-il dans ce conflit est-ce
que Monsieur Erdogan a eu cette
déclaration c'est une est-ce une
première rappelez-vous il avait qualifié
Madame Merkel de
nazi la parole de Monsieur Erdogan est
dirigé vers l'intérieur vers sa
clientèle il a des élections chez lui et
du
coup sa parole n'a pas de portée
diplomatique elle a de une portée de
politique intérieure évidemment ça
laisse des trace et cet allié de l'OTAN
ce pilier de l'OTAN critique
systématique depuis des années l'OTAN
l'Europe et se rapproche de la Russie
donc il joue un jou un jeu extrêmement
trouble et n'est pas crédible dans ce
qu'il dit vous ne diriez pas quand même
que ce conflit est en train d'accélérer
la PO la polarisation du monde entre
monde occidental et et le reste du monde
est-ce qu'il y a pas un clivage
important qui est en train de se créer
autour de ce conflit oui il a été créé
d'abord à cause ou à l'occasion de de de
la guerre en Ukraine donc il y a le le
sud global qui qui qui s'organise et qui
isole en quelque sorte les expuissances
occidentales euh effectivement ce
conflitl vient accélérer son mouvement
et démontrer que cette tendance cette
dynamique s'installe dans la durée
est-ce que vous êtes inquiet par exemple
de voir la montée de l'antisémitisme en
France mais finalement un peu partout
dans le monde on a vu aux États-Unis ces
derniers jours est-ce que c'est cette
polarisation elle passe par là aussi
j'ai vu hier dans la presse que cette
montée de l'antisémitisme était provoqué
par des agents étrangers j'ai lu dans la
presse je sais pas si c'est vrai la
justice n'a pas parlé encore qu'il y a
deux couples de Russes euh qui qui
s'étent manifesté pour taguer pour
pousser cet antisémitisme si c'est le
cas et bien on voit bien on verrait bien
à ce moment-là que c'est une c'est une
situation de provocation euh à la haine
que les agents d'une puissance étrangère
sont en train de de de d'installer en
France pour l'exploiter qu'en est-il
dans le monde arabe de cette montée
qu'on voit dans nos pays excidentaux
l'antisémitisme est-ce que c'est la même
chose qu'est-ce que euh ça ne leur parle
pas parce que ils ont d'autres chat
fouetté ils sont préoccupés par leur
propre sort et par le sort de de leur
amis ou proches à Gaza quand il y a ce
ce ce déluge de bombe sur Gaza il se
préoccupe moins de tag sur les portes
euh des magasins ou des habitations en
Occident ça leur parle pas beaucoup ils
sont préoccupés par des choses qui leur
semblent beaucoup plus proches et
beaucoup plus immédiates dans leur
environnement est-ce que vous diriez
aujourd'hui que ce conflit est en train
de s'exporter au monde entier finalement
il provoque des des des
fractures j'ai vu qu'il y a des des
diplomates des haut fonctionnaires
américains qui ont démissionné parce
qu'ils n'ont pas approuvé la politique
de leur gouvernement généralement des
diplomates ne vont pas jusqu'à la
démission donc ça crée une
crispation à tous les niveaux dans tous
les pays effectivement quand on voit ce
qui se passe on peut pas rester
indifférent un un dernier mot sur un
autre sujet monsieur Basbous puisque le
Sénat examine en ce moment même la loi
immigration ce texte vise notamment à
faciliter les expulsions mais on sait
que beaucoup de pays notamment des pays
arabes ne veulent pas reprendre leurs
ressortissant est-ce qu'il faut durcir
nos relations avec ces pays pour les
contraindre d'abord la France est
souveraine et doit pouvoir légiférer
et les pays arabes ou les autres les
pays autres nont qu'à se soumettre en
quelque sorte aux lois françaises voté
alors si par exemple le un un expulsé
est né en France il a le passeport
français et bien les pays arabes ne sont
pas obligé de le reprendre parce qu'ils
vont dire au à la France mais vous
l'avez éduqué dans vos écoles dans vos
quartiers ce sont des cas qui sont
produits à main reprise donc du de ce
fait il pourrait ne pas être très
partant pour recueillir des doubles
nationaux qui ont vécu qui sont né qui
ont vécu qui ont la sociité française et
qu'ils ne se se sentent pas comme un
dépottoir en quelque sorte vous n'en
voulez plus bon on découvre qu'il a une
double nationalité on le repousse en
dehors des frontières donc la France a
besoin d'être plus ferme avec ses
ressortissants et avec ses parten àcir
les relations avec ses parten
effectivement évidemment est-ce que vous
direz que cette question l'immigration
complique les relations entre la France
et les pays arabes et entre les pays
occidentaux et et le reste du monde
aussi je crois que on peut pas échapper
à cette nouvelle loi
euh dirit que ça va devenir un problème
majeur ces question d'immigration c'est
un problème d'abord franco-français euh
d'abord parce que le débat en France est
extrêmement sévère sur cette sur cette
sur cette problématique et puis une fois
que la loi aura été votée il va falloir
l'appliquer de façon c'est ça de façon
ferme
et entière merci Antoine Basbous merci
beaucoup d'avoir été notre invité ce
matin on remonte votre livre le tsunami
arabe s paru chez Fayard merci d'avoir
été avec nous la Une de La Dépêche
Christelle tout autre sujet c'est le
procès jubilar l'heure de vérité puisque
le parquet vient de demander le renvoi
de jubilard devant la Cour d'Assise
merci beaucoup Christelle merci Monsieur
Basbous on passe au club de
territoires